bu
Sesim geliyor değil mi Evet Herkese
merhaba burada olmak çok heyecanlı
Sizleri görmek çok heyecanlı Az önce
dışarıda arkadaşlarla ilk cümle ne
olacak diye konuşurken dedim ki İçeride
karar vereceğim
halıya baktım Çok belirgin bir halı
sınırları Çok belirgin
dışarısı siyah Ben siyah noktadan geldim
Ve şimdi kırmızı halı üzerindeyim önce
dışarıdaydım Şimdi ise içerdeyim Şimal
Az önce dinle yendim şimdi konuşalım
az önce başka bir sürü rollerle
Dışarıdaydım şimdi
daha çok Terapist rolümle burada
olacağım Ailedeki diğer roller imle
tümörlerinde burada olacağım size
kendimden bahsedeceğim aslında bu olan
diye düşünüyorum
fotoğraflar paylaşacağım sunumda yaşam
çizimdeki renkler dedim Çünkü ben
renklerin her rengin güzelliğine inanan
bir bireyim ve çektiğim kendi çok basit
çektiğim fotoğrafları koydum buraya
Çünkü onların içinde duygu var Kendim
çektim bir duyguyla çektim o
fotoğrafları içeriye bende saklı ve o
duygularımla şu anda bu sahnede
buluyorum
burada bir kapıyı gördüğünüz gibi
bazen o kapının içinde oluyorum dışarıya
bakıyorum bazen kapının dışında olup
kendi dünyamı da bakıyorum bunu mesleki
olarak da yaparken şimdi hayattaki tüm
rollerim de bu şekilde bakmaya
çalışıyorum Ve kendimle ilgili
farkındalığı her an Yaşamaya çalışıyorum
ben hep gelir Ah
ah Evet ben şunlardan bahsetmek
istiyorum yaşam çizgi dedim değil mi
size yaşam çizgimiz de aslına bakarsanız
rollerimiz de var oluyoruz nedir roller
Terapist rolüm anne rolüm eş rolüm
kardeş rolüm arkadaş rolüm hayatta
birçok rollerimiz var bu rollerle var
oluyoruz bir diğeri ise değerlerim Ben
değerlerim de varım Mesela ben neden şu
an bu sahnedeyim Çünkü ben birtakım
değerlere sahibim dikse konuşma yapmak
istiyorum Neden Çünkü sizlerle paylaşım
yapmayı seviyorum paylaşıma dair bir
değerim var benim ilham olmak istiyorum
ilham olmaya ilham vermeye dair bir
değerim var bu derim ortaya koyabilirim
takdirde mutlu olabileceğimi İnanıyorum
o yüzden de değerleri bu değerlerimizi
Herkesin kendine özgü yaşam değerlerine
saygı duyuyorum bir diğeri ise benim
yaşam çizgim de duygularım çok kıymetli
Çünkü az önce dedim duygularımla
buradayım kendi çektiği fotoğraflarla
buradayım Çünkü onlar için de duygu
gizli duygularım benim beni harekete
geçiriyor hayatta ve o harekette baka
bir şeyler öğreniyorum hayata dair
öğrenme ile ilgili de bir değeri var
Çünkü
bu diyerek hayattaki birçok renkten
bahsedeceğiz benim hayatımdaki
renklerden Aslında örnekler vererek
biraz
gerçekten yol gösterici olmaya
çalışacağım istediklerinizi alın lütfen
bunlardan istediklerinizi de Bırakın
burada ve çıkıp gidin
Benim çektiğim bir fotoğraf ve bakın
orada birçok renk sandalye mevcut ancak
bu kısmı bir arada dururken bir tanesi
orada tek başına bir arada Duranlar daha
düzenli sıralanmış iç içe geçmiş yan
yana Durmuş Farklı renkler olmalarına
rağmen ancak diğeri tek başına ve
devrilmiş
şu düşündüm o fotoğrafı çekerken hepimiz
farklı şeyler düşünebilirsiniz diyoruz
ya duygularımıza var oluyoruz diye
buradaki herkes bu fotoğrafa baktığımda
farklı şey hissedebilir Hissettiğim şey
şu
sandalye devrilmiş olan sandalye asla
Size uygun olmayan bir cümle kuracağım
Kusura bakmayın başarısızlığı gösteriyor
Belki de biraz düşmek devrilmek değil mi
roller içerisinde Aslında korktuğumuz
şeydir bu hep başarılı olmalıyız mutlu
olmalıyız devrilme meliyiz işte grupla
hareket etmeliyiz gibi birtakım roller
veriliyor bizi acaba ama ben sandalye de
aslında çok kıymetli
Bu nedenle de ben birazcık size
başarısızlıklarından da bahsedeceğim
burada çünkü başarısızlıklarından da çok
şey öğrendiğimi görüyorum ve Biliyorum
biliyorum ki geçmişteki olayları
değiştiremeyeceği onlar var oldu Şu anda
da hala hayatımda var geçmişteki iyi
yaşantıların ve olumsuz yaşantıların
hepsi benimle birlikte var Ancak bakış
açımı değiştirmeliyim şu anda Ben 10 yıl
önce baktığım zaman on yıl önce olayı
yaşarken ki duyguyla bakmıyorum ya da
düşüncem de bakmıyorum aldım değişti
Artık bu şekilde baktığımız zaman
hayatta psikolojik esneklik sağlamış
oluyoruz kendimize O yüzden bunu çok
önemsiyorum çünkü diyorum ki kriz
Aslında içinde fırsatları da
barındırıyor
Ama ben bunu terapi seanslarında mutlaka
dile getiriyorum Çünkü Evet biliyorsunuz
problemlerle geliyor
insanlar bana ve diyorum ki hepsi birer
fırsat büyük acılarla geliyorlar ama o
acılardan de öğrendiklerine bakıyoruz
hep beraber ve öğrendikleri bundan
sonraki yaşantısını nasıl etki edecek
bunu nasıl olumlu bir şekilde kullanacak
Biz bunlara bakıyoruz ve ben kendi
yaşantımda da bunu aynı şekilde
uygulayarak danışanları mla birlikte yol
alıyorum zaten seansları ma başlarken
hep şunu söyleyeyim Bu bir yolculuk ve
ikimizin yolculuğu ya da üçümüzün aile
terapileri seansları mızda oluyor
birlikte yolculuğumuz Bu sadece sizin
yolculuğunuz değil Ben de sizden çok şey
öğreneceğim burada
benim ilk başarısızlığı mı sunuyorum ben
kız sesi mezunuyum mal ve Akademik
olarak çok iyi olduğuna inanıldığı için
okula gönderildim ve ardından Kız
Lisesinden Başarılı bir şekilde mezun
olan Meltem üniversite sınavını
kazanamadı ailede korkunç bir hayal
kırıklığı yaşandı ve ben kendi odama
kendi yatağıma çekildim sanki dünyanın
en büyük başarısızlığı ymış gibi geldi
bana
sonra dedim ki şu an o yıllara baktığım
zaman 90'lı yıllara baktığım zaman
diyorum ki şu an kullanılan fil Budizm
diye bir kavram var duymuş olabilirsiniz
hayatta her şey mutluluk üzerine kurulu
değil başta dedim ya duygularımızdan
bahsettim her türlü duyguyu ihtiyacımız
var sadece mutluluğa değil kaygıya da
üzüntüye de öfkeler ede ihtiyacımız var
işte orada Yaşadığım hayal kırıklığı
üzüntü
korkunç depresyon duygusu Beni ayağa
kaldırdı
bu şekilde oturdum Çünkü Durdum Durdum
ve düşündüm
ardından yeniden hazırlanarak sınava bir
şekilde yine ailemin istediği bir bölüm
olan fizik bölümünü kazandım ve fizik
bölümünü kazanmakta benim için
başarısızlıkta ailem için başarıyla
çevremdeki herkes için başarıydı ama
benim için başarısızlık tıbbı Çünkü
istemiyordum ve yeniden Ben üniversite
ortamında bir Psikolojik destek aldım
ardından hocamla Birlikte karar vererek
bölüm değişikliği yaparak psikolojik
danışmanlık ve rehberlik bölümünü
okumaya karar verdim ve İzmir yolculuğun
başladığı
İzmir bir şehir değişikliği oldu benim
için Adana'dan sonraki Biz çok büyük ve
çok kapalı bir aileyiz Aslında o nedenle
aileden ilk kez dışarı çıkan bir bireyin
bir torunum aslına bakarsanız heyecan oy
kullandı bu
Evet
ne oldu ben acıyla temas etmiştim değil
mi Aslında üniversite sınavını
kazanamadığım zaman bir acıya dokunduğum
o acı bana dokundu Acaba ben acıyı temiz
acı ve kirli olarak kirli acı olarak
ayırıyoruz Kabule kararlılık terapisinde
bu acıyı kirli acıya çevirmedim temiz
acı olarak Evet
duydum ancak ayağa kalkabilmek için bu
acıyı temiz acı olarak cebimde tutmam
gerekiyordu sakince cebimde tuttum ve
sonra o acı yine sakince kendimden
uzaklaştırarak yeniden ayağa kalktım ve
kendi düşünce ve duygularımla ilgili de
birçok farkındalık elde ettim
üç kaynakların doğru bulup kendi güç
kaynaklarını doğru olarak bulamasaydın
Eğer ya bulacağım yerleri bulamasaydın
mesela Psikolojik destek benim için
tutunacağım bir yerde buna Saydım eğer
doğru kıyafeti üstümü giyemeden fizik
bölümünde okumuş mezun olmuş gayet
mutsuz bir insan olarak hayatına devam
edecektim Belki de ki sevilmeyen bir
öğretmen olacak birçok gence maalesef
olumsuz bir rol model olacaktı
Dolayısıyla
burada ardından gelen ayağa kalkmak
Kendime uygun kıyafeti giymek benim
tercihimde ve o cesareti gösterebilmek
bugün benim Özellikle anlatmak istediğim
şey
şehir değişikliğinde yeni rollerim oldu
yeni değerler elde ettim ve baktım ki
yeni duygular oluştu hayatımda Aslında
benim hayatıma bakarsanız sadece bir
tane öncesi ve sonrası before-after yok
birçok var beni Ya aslında ve sıra saygı
duyuyorum
Bütün bunlardan bir şeyler öğrendiğini
görüyorum çünkü çünkü ben şikayet
etmiyorum şikayette bir aksiyon olabilir
ama doğru adım atabilmek her şeyden
önemli diye düşünüyorum uyum sağlıyorum
yani
değişikliği yaptım üniversiteyi
bitirdikten sonra dedim ki bu da
yetmiyor Meltem yurtdışı yapmam lazım
Yeni kültürler Tanımam lazım Beni York'a
gittim
cebimde 150 doları vardı Hiç unutmuyorum
ve dedim ki aynı zamanda çalışmamda
gerekiyor hem çalıştım Hatta üniversite
Dokuz Eylül
Üniversitesi'nde
bulunduğum sıralarda Hocam dedi ki gel
benim okulum var sana okulum var orada
çalış dedi ve orada çalışmaya başladım
Bütün bunlar hayatımda Aslında
daha çok benim burnumu soktuğum alanlar
oldu Evet bu da dile getirmeyi çok
seviyorum ben burnunuzu sokun lütfen Hiç
Kimse gelip size Gel şurada şunu yap
böyle yapalım gibi fırsatları önünüzde
alıp vermiyor bir şekilde adım atmamız
gerekiyor burada adımları beklemeniz
için o adımları bekleme hakkına sahip
olmanız için önce sizin adım atmamız
gerekiyor Çünkü ben üniversitedeyken
Dokuz Eylül Üniversitesi'nde kendi
psikiyatri kliniklerinde Çukurova
Üniversitesi'nde yazın psikiyatri
kliniklerinde görüntü staj yaptım kışın
da Okulu'nda da Ege Üniversitesi'nde
psikiyatri kliniklerinde Ben gönüllü
stajlar yaptım şunu hiç kimse bana
söylemedi Gel demedi Ben gittim adım
attım yani bir aksiyon aldım ve
Amerika'da
bu en önemli şey şu Aslında ben nargile
bunu da yaşadım Amerika'da O da benim
için bir dönüm noktası oldu diye
düşünüyorum Çünkü ikiz binalar yıkıldı
zaman orta yazdım o da benim için
gerçekten before-after oldu çünkü
orada ha hayata tanıklık ettim Ciddi bir
tarihe tanıklık ettim vb orada
arkadaşlarımı kaybettim çok fazla
arkadaşımı itfaiyeci arkadaşlarım vardı
onları kaybettim özellikle onlar çok
kıymetliydi benim için ve ardından çok
sevdiğim bir arkadaşımı kaybettim O da
benim için gerçekten Bir dönüm noktası
oldu ardından dedim ki benim sevdiğim
Başka insanlar da var hayatta ve ülkeme
döneyim döndüm bir çocuk sahibi olarak
bu arada Amerika'da bir çocuk sahibi
oldum ve ardından tek başıma gidip üç
kişi beraber Türkiye döndük ikiye
döndüğüm zaman Aslında sevmediğim bir
ama maalesef Adana'ya dönmüştüm Çünkü
asıl dönmek istediğini yeriz Mehdi Ancak
bu da bana çok şey öğretti ve dedim ki
Meltem Acaba
sen nasıl bir bahçe yaratmak istiyorsun
o bahçeyi düzenlemek senin elinde
bakımsız
berbat bir bahçede sahip olabilirsin Hiç
bakmak istemediğin arkadaşlarını
sevdiklerini ağırlamak istemediğin ama
harika bir bahçeye de sahip olabilirsin
bunu bu senin elinde dedim bu senin
kontrolünde
Dolayısıyla kendi bahçemi yeniden
yaratmaya başladım ve mesleki
değişimlerinde başladı Aslında
bazen bu mesleki değişimlerini Teşekkür
ederim tanıtım yapılırken
bunları da hatırlatmış oldu bana Mesela
devlet kurumlarında çalıştım Özel
sektörde çalıştım ve yaşamın birçok
alanında
mesela Türkçeyi bilmeyen Doğu bölgesinde
Türkçeyi bilmeyen çocuklarla da çalıştım
yetişkinlerde de çalıştım
Hattaba ebeveynleri bana diyorlardı ki
ya hocam Boş ver bizi çağırma buraya Sen
ne yapıyorsan yap hemen gerekiyorsa döv
bunlarla da karşılaştım ama onlarla baş
etmek ve sadece kendimi sevdirmek bile
yetti biliyor musunuz Neden Çünkü
değişimi başlatmak gerekiyordu
insanlarda değişimi başlatabilmek için
dedim ki yine Meltem sadece sevsinler ve
sana güvensinler bunu sağlamaya çalıştım
ve ardından o da bana yeni bir yaşam
deneyimi sağladı
bu ve pandemi geldi mi pandemi ile
birlikte yeniden Bir dönüm noktası
yaşadım kendi adıma Yeni kararlar almam
gerekiyordu çünkü Hayattaki her şey
kontrolümde
olamayabiliyor Dukan David'e bana bunu
anlattı ve dedim ki kendime Meltem Yeni
kararlar alabilirsin Çünkü şunu Evet
dünyada yolunda gitmeyen bir şeyler var
Sen bunu kontrol edemiyorsun ama seni
görebileceğim bir şeyler var Bunu keşfet
iç dünyama döndüm ve dedim ki artık
kurumsal olarak çalışmayı bırakıyorsun
ve bireysel olarak senin
özgürlük değerlerini kapsayan bir takım
ihtiyaçlarım var bireysel olarak
çalışmaya başladım çok sevdiğim çok
değer verdiğim kurumdan isteyerek
ayrıldım
sevgiyle hem de ardından bireysel olarak
çalışmaya başladım şimdi ise hem da
rahimde İzmir'de ofisim var ve bu
şekilde birçok insana birçok aileye
birçok çocuğa Ergene yetişkine destek
vermeye çalışıyorum Hem de Büyük bir
keyifle onlarla birlikte yol olarak
Çünkü diyorum ki virginia's at ya şunu
söylüyor problemler problem değildir
aslında onlarla baş etme Şeklimiz
problemdir bir nasıl baş ettiğimiz çok
önemli
Dur
bakalım bundan sonraki gelecek mi bu
abone ol
bu
peki Hayatta hep prizler var değil mi Şu
anda da bir kriz yaşıyorum ama stratejik
olmak gerçekten hayatta çok önemli ve
yeni dönemlerde pandemi sonrasında ise
yeni bir dönem başladı Benim İçin tüm
dünyada başladığı gibi bende de yeni bir
dönem başladı ve baktığımız zaman
Aslında o hep mutlu olmak hep Hızlı
Yaşamak dışında bir şeydi yaşadığımız
şey değil mi birçoğumuz için durmamız
gerekiyordu evde olmamız en güzel yerde
olmamız gerekiyordu ve birçok anlamda
mutluluk yoktu hayatımızda bu da bana
çok şey öğretti ve yeni kararlar
almamızı sağladı bakın her kriz bir
fırsattır diyorum her fırsatta
söylüyorum
ve böylece davranış yapar tarımı çok
fazla genişlet Tim ve kendime psikolojik
esneklik sağlamaya çalıştım Ne kadar çok
davranış çeşitliliğimiz var bu hayatta o
kadar esnek davranırız Kendimize karşı
hoşgörüsüz artar ve böylece yaşam
çekilir hale gelir çok daha keyifli hale
gelir Yoksa acı her zaman var
hayatımızda da ama bu acıya Sizin nasıl
dokunduğunuz nasıl temas ettiğiniz
Hoca'yı alıp bir süre üstünüzde taşıyıp
ardından Hoşçakal diye bilmeniz lazım
Bunun içinde davranış repertuar mızı
lütfen geliştirin
çünkü hep sevdiğim bir sözdür bu
yorulduğunda Pes Etme dinlen dinlen ve
tekrar ayağa kalk Bu da ünlü Boksör
Muhammed Ali'nin sözüdür O nedenle Hayır
izin vermiyorum da diye bilmek gerekiyor
Ben bazen durmak gerekiyor bu ve yol
alabilmek için
ilerlemek gerekiyor adım atmak gerekiyor
ve Şimdi en son size şunu soruyorum
kendinize buradan çıkar kendin ki evet
Meltem Hanım burada bir sunum yaptım
şöyle davranmaya karar verdim onu
söylediklerinden sonra şöyle davranmaya
karar verdim Meltem Hanım'ın şu
söylediklerine katılmıyorum bu da lütfen
cebinize Koyun ya da şu söylediklerine
katılıyorum da cebinize koyup gidin Bu
da bir farkındalıktır her şeyi aynı anda
beraber düşünmek hissetmek zorunda
değiliz diye düşünüyorum o nedenle
diyorum ki buradan çıkarken kendinize 20
yıl sonra şöyle bir dönüp bakın 20 yıl
sonra hangi konuda bir ödül vermek
isterdiniz hangi konudan Ya sen bu işi
yani değerlerin şuydu senin Mesela
seyahat etmekte senin değerinin
konusunda Gerçekten bu bu hak ediyorsun
dediğiniz bir konuyu Lütfen buradan
giderken düşünün ve kendinize o ödülü
verebilmek için neler yapacağınızı Belki
de hayal ederek başlayabilirsiniz Çok
teşekkür ediyorum Çok sağ olun